[Música]
queridos amigos amigas la pregunta que
muchos os estáis haciendo estos días es
hasta qué punto china va a apoyar a
Rusia en la Guerra de Ucrania Esta es
Por así decirlo una de las piezas que
faltan en todo este puzzle china es la
mayor potencia rival de Estados Unidos y
teóricamente si apoyara decididamente a
Moscú el balance de fuerzas podría
cambiar radicalmente
[Música]
ahora bien esta es la teoría pero ocurre
lo mismo con la realidad Hasta qué punto
estaría china dispuesta a involucrarse
pues para responder a estas preguntas lo
primero de todo es resolver otra
pregunta qué demonios piensa el gobierno
Chino Sobre la invasión de Ucrania pues
una cosa y la otra que sí pero que no
porque amigos por un lado China antes de
la invasión llevaba ya tiempo diciendo
cosas como esta mensajes que luego he
ido repitiendo una y otra vez sí
respalda la oposición de Putin a la
expansión de la otan en una Cumbre que
subraya lazos más estrechos y además
durante las primeras horas de la
invasión también dijeron cosas como esta
hemos declarado la posición principal de
China sobre la cuestión de Ucrania hay
un trasfondo histórico y un contexto
complejo en este asunto el Ministerio de
defensa ruso dijo que sus fuerzas
armadas no van a llevar a cabo ataques
con misiles aéreos o de artillería en
ciudades oachun directora adjunta del
departamento de información del
Ministerio de relaciones exteriores de
la República popular china ya sabéis que
es todo muy complicado que no iban a
atacar a civiles en fin que es una
operación limitada que la abuela fuma
etcétera etcétera y así siguieron
pasando los días hasta que invasión de
Ucrania china se abstiene de votar en la
resolución del Consejo de Seguridad de
la ONU para condenar a Rusia y amigos ya
sabéis que hay silencios que resultan
astronadores la abstención de China tuvo
que ser toda una sorpresa para el
kremlin O tal vez no
fuera como fuese El caso es que los
chinos abandonaron a los rusos en la
votación y el kremlin contó solo con el
apoyo de Bielorrusia Siria Corea del
Norte y eritrea menudo Club toda una
puñalada para la supuesta historia de
amor que sillín y Vladimir Putin han
protagonizado en los últimos años porque
amigos pocos líderes acumulan tantas
citas para que os hagáis una idea los
presidentes de Rusia y de China se han
visto las caras y frotado las manos unas
40 veces Incluso se dice que para no
aguarle la fiesta a los chinos pudines
pero a que terminaran los Juegos
Olímpicos de Pekín para lanzar su
invasión Pero por qué china Entonces no
apoya a Rusia en esta guerra sacará
acaso Pekín provecho de toda esta
situación hoy vamos a responder a estas
preguntas pero antes antes veamos un
poco de historia
[Música]
destinados a entenderse
la unión soviética lideró al bloque
comunista durante la Guerra Fría y en
sus primeros años contó con el apoyo del
país más poblado de la tierra la china
de maosetun juntos estaban llamados a
plantar cara al sistema capitalista de
occidente sin embargo amigos las
relaciones entre Moscú y Pekín se
torcieron después de la muerte de
Stanley
poco a poco las disputas entre chinos y
soviéticos fueron cada vez más sonadas
hasta que en 1969 llegaron a producirse
enfrentamientos armados entre las tropas
de ambos países a lo largo de la
frontera la frontera de más de 6.000
kilómetros entre China y la unión
soviética estuvo fuertemente
militarizada durante décadas la extinta
urs mantuvo 44 divisiones desplegadas
hasta finales de los 80 13 divisiones
más que en el frente occidental contra
la ota
[Música]
pero tras la caída de la unión soviética
Rusia china mejoraron bastante sus
relaciones e impulsaron una serie de
encuentros junto con otros países de
Asia central eran conocidos Como los
cinco de Shanghai y Su objetivo era
definir claramente las fronteras por
soviéticas algo que resultaba
fundamental para reducir las tropas
desplegadas con el tiempo estos
encuentros se transformaron en toda una
organización internacional la
organización de cooperación de Shanghai
a la que visualpolitik por cierto le
dedicamos Este vídeo
actualmente la ocs ha ampliado sus
objetivos y forma parte de la estrategia
de China y Rusia para construir
organizaciones internacionales al margen
de las instituciones que diseñó Estados
Unidos al acabar la Segunda Guerra
Mundial de hecho China y Rusia han
intentado sacar su propia alternativa al
Swift ahora por cierto que la mayoría de
los bancos rusos no pueden usar el Swift
es muy probable que se pasen al cips que
es un sistema creado por china
ojo no os equivoquéis el tips todavía
está años luz del clásico Swift ni
siquiera compiten en la misma liga el
Swift es el sistema utilizado por más de
11.000 instituciones financieras de más
de 200 países diferentes mientras que
apenas 1.200 instituciones en solo 100
países utilizan el sistema chino además
en muchas dudas de que este sistema
puede usarse realmente en Rusia sin
problemas por qué pues atentos el
sistema de pago transfronterizon joanes
todavía depende de los bancos como nodos
que pueden sancionados e influenciados
Estados Unidos puede sancionar a estos
bancos chem SIM profesor del instituto
avanzado de finanzas de Shanghai 2014
fue un punto de inflexión cuando el
kremlin seneccionó occidente castigó con
sanciones a Rusia y desde entonces a
Putin no la quedó otra que mirar más y
más hacia Oriente Por cierto un apunte
curioso china todavía hoy sigue sin
reconocer la anexión rusa de crimea
sorpresa
pero regresando al terreno económico
pensadlo bien china Aparentemente es un
socio comercial perfecto para Rusia
China tiene tecnología Pero le falta
recursos naturales mientras que Rusia
les sobra los recursos pero no tiene
tecnología Así que blanco y en botella
desde 2014 el business entre Moscú y
Pekín no ha parado de crecer los datos
de 2021 hablan por sí solos el comercio
entre China y Rusia alcanza un récord de
más de 140.000 millones de dólares de
esta forma china se ha convertido en el
mayor mercado para las exportaciones
rusas después de la Unión Europea y la
mitad de lo que china le compra Rusia es
petróleo crudo pero también compran
carbón gas natural y armas por su parte
los rusos han mostrado mucho pero que
mucho interés en la tecnología china no
les queda otra por ejemplo Huawei está
llamada jugar un papel destacado en el
desarrollo del 5g en Rusia Bueno cuando
este llegue quiero decir porque claro
hablando de Rusia puede que donde dicen
5g terminen convirtiéndose en dos y
medio y algún que otro mega yate en
chipre ya me entendéis El caso es que en
este punto estaban las relaciones chinos
rusas cuando Putin desató su tormenta de
fuego y instrucción sobre Ucrania y la
pregunta es cómo ha reaccionado Pekín al
ataque ruso Pues bien Ahora mismo te lo
contamos
[Música]
la guerra de Putin
amigos en los últimos Juegos Olímpicos
de invierno china se impuso en el
medallero las competiciones de gimnasia
ahora bien os aseguro que la
flexibilidad de los diplomáticos del
gigante asiático no tiene nada que
envidiar a la de sus gimnastas los que
seguís visual política habitualmente
Seguro seguro que habéis oído hablar de
la conferencia de seguridad de Munich se
celebra todos los años en febrero y de
hecho visual política participó en la de
2020 pero esa es otra historia El caso
es que la conferencia del 2022 participó
por videoconferencia el ministro de
exteriores chino o allí y así de firme
se mostró cuando le preguntaron por las
tensiones en la frontera de Ucrania ojo
quedaban cinco días para la invasión
fijaos
bien No creo que se puede decir más alto
pero no más claro lo que pasa es que es
muy fácil ser tan contundente cuando el
statu quo se mantiene y todo está más o
menos tranquilo pero claro cuando de
repente sale Putin en la tele y dice que
las tropas rusas se disponen a cruzar la
frontera a ella la cosa cambia por
completo y tal y como decimos en
visualpolitik dicho y hecho
fue empezar la invasión y el gobierno
chino comenzamos a mostrarse muy pero
que muy incómodo como que de repente
tenían que buscar excusas y
justificaciones a lo que Putin estaba
haciendo es más el mismo 24 de febrero
con la invasión ya iniciada la portavoz
del ministerio chino de exteriores
intentó hasta convencernos de que la
Guerra de Ucrania ni siquiera era una
guerra
el resto es historia Rusia ha usado la
artillería y todos hemos visto las
imágenes de harkie y Mario Paul
devastadas por los rusos Así que china
poco a poco empezó a moverse a moverse
así como de perfil tratando de que no se
les Viera mucho el problema El problema
es que china pertenece al consejo de
seguridad de la ONU Así que cuando este
consejo se reunió para pronunciarse
sobre la invasión de Ucrania a China no
le quedó más remedio de votar y la
pregunta es qué pensáis que voto China
[Música]
pues amigos hizo lo mismo que con la
anexión de crimea abstenerse y evitar
criticar la actuación de Putin bueno es
que ni siquiera los medios de
comunicación oficiales de China han
hablado de invasión de hecho el
representante de china en la ONU acusó a
la otan de causar todos los problemas ya
sabéis la típica excusa habitual de que
la culpa de la agresión es de todo el
mundo menos de quién la lleva a
cabot
true name en
fantasmations
atención
pero al fin y al cabo qué otra cosa iba
a decir china pero ojo porque esto
tampoco supone un respaldo claro para
Moscú y de hecho desde entonces el
gobierno chino ha evitado dar más pasos
en falso mantiene que no le gusta lo que
está ocurriendo en Ucrania que defiende
su integridad territorial y que Apuesta
por resolver esta actuación mediante el
diálogo aún así también sostiene que
Rusia tiene sus ra actuar que cómo se
puede estar del lado del agresor y del
agredido al mismo tiempo pues qué
queréis que os diga no tengo ni idea
Supongo que será cosa de hacer malabares
El caso es que está claro que china no
gana nada con esta guerra e incluso
podríamos llegar a decir que le importa
más bien poco esta amigos es la guerra
de Putin y a los chinos ni les viene no
van a quemar sus naves ni por Rusia ni
por Ucrania y mucho menos después de
haber visto Cuál ha sido la reacción de
occidente
[Música]
suficientes problemas tienen yanchiná
con la crisis inmobiliaria la
desaceleración económica y sus tormentos
a relaciones con los países vecinos como
para meterse en un berenjenal sin
sentido además todos sabemos Cuál es el
principal objetivo de China más aún
teniendo en cuenta cómo se está
comportando los últimos meses china
ordena la mayor incursión de aviones de
combate en la zona de defensa de Taiwán
desde octubre de hecho fueron muchos los
analistas que se preguntaron si no
pensaba imitar a Putin Y aprovechar la
ocasión para invadirte igual claro que
para el comunismo chino las dos
situaciones son muy diferentes Ucrania
es un país soberano y reconocido
internacionalmente en cambio Taiwán está
reconocido como país soberano
prácticamente por ningún país ni
siquiera por los propios Estados Unidos
y de hecho poner en duda la soberanía de
Ucrania es algo que juega directamente
en contra de la propia china ya que
validaría que otros hicieran lo mismo
con Taiwán que pusieran en cuestión la
soberanía China qué Pekín tanto se
empeñan defender precisamente por eso el
gobierno de parece tener claro que este
no es el momento de China Eso sí la
guerra de ucranial les está sirviendo de
aprendizaje por ejemplo están viendo
Cuáles son las armas que occidente está
dispuesta a utilizar para frenar a una
potencia nuclear
y además es que todo indica que ante una
invasión de Taiwán la oposición de
Estados Unidos sería todavía mayor Al
fin y al cabo Taiwán es uno noveno socio
comercial más grande y toda una
superpotencia en semiconductores
Asimismo Tenemos que tener en cuenta que
unas hipotéticas sanciones para frenar
el comercio con occidente serían algo
letal para la economía china una
economía que aún depende de las
importaciones de occidente para poder
operar muchos sectores estratégicos y
amigos esto nos lleva directamente a una
reflexión que creo es importante la
batería de sanciones con las que los
aliados no dejan de bombarde
económicamente a Moscú Podría tener una
lectura más que interesante en términos
militares para el mundo y especialmente
para los propios chinos si las nuevas
guerras del futuro ya no se libran solo
en el campo de batalla quizás no sea tan
prioritario invertir más y más y más en
tratar de tener el ejército más fuerte
salvo si eres vecino del Vladimir Claro
está pero no nos desviemos todo esto no
quiere decir que los chinos No se estén
planteando Cómo sacar tajada del tiro en
el pie que se ha pegado Útil para nada
fijaos
el botín de Pin
[Música]
amigos una de las sanciones más
importantes que se han impuesto contra
Rusia es precisamente la que actúa
contra su Banco Central al que se le han
congelado sus reservas de Divisas en
esta línea china puede haber tomado
buena nota porque evitar que en un
futuro le apliquen esta sanción a ella
puede resultarle clave Al fin y al cabo
china es el país que tiene las mayores
reservas de Divisas de todo el mundo
hablamos de aproximadamente el
equivalente a 3,22 millones de dólares
unas reservas en las que por cierto la
moneda estadounidense es la predominante
el gobierno de sillín ha sido muy
crítico con las sanciones y no tiene
porque aplicarlas pero lo cierto Es que
como mínimo seguro que actuará con mucha
cautela antes de tomar cualquier
decisión que amenace su acceso al
sistema financiero internacional si ya
lo hizo con los suyos cuando Estados
Unidos sancionó a algunos dirigentes de
Hong Kong que no hará con los rusos y en
lo que respecta al comercio tres cuartas
partes de lo mismo porque por mucho que
los intercambios con Rusia va tan
récords de momento apenas representan
una décima parte de su comercio
combinado con Estados Unidos y la Unión
Europea
Pero entonces qué podría querer China de
Rusia a cambio de su respaldo si lo
pensáis bien tienen que ser cosas en las
que Pekín salga muy beneficiada porque
en este momento aceptados con Rusia no
está bien visto
[Música]
Pues bien Por ejemplo un campo que
preocupa y mucha china es la seguridad
alimentaria antes de la guerra los
precios mundiales de los alimentos ya
estaban en máximos de la última década y
ahora los expertos señalan que la
invasión de Ucrania amenaza de
suministro mundial de trigo china
levanta restricciones a las
importaciones de trigo Ruso y por
supuesto está el tema del gas su consumo
de gas natural se ha multiplicado por
tres en la última década y como la
producción nacional no llega a cubrir el
60% de su demanda el resto pues lo
tienen que importar la mayor parte lo
consigue mediante gas natural licuado El
problema del gnl es que es bastante más
caro que el gas que llega Por gasoducto
y seguro que aquí a muchos os vendrá una
pregunta a la cabeza Oye Enrique pero
acaso Rusia no es el gran suministrador
de gas Europa no podría hacer acaso lo
mismo con china Pues sí pero actualmente
Rusia apenas le ofrece a China en torno
al 15% del gas que el gigante asiático
importa Claro que un momento porque eso
va a cambiar bastante Durante los
próximos años
en 2019 entró en Operación el gasoducto
power of Siberia que estará pleno
rendimiento en el 2025 además en el
último encuentro entre Putin y se cerró
un acuerdo adicional para suministrar
gas a través de una nueva ruta y la
invasión de Ucrania de momento no ha
cambiado esta tendencia
en el camino hacia un nuevo acuerdo de
gas con china mientras las sanciones
golpean a Rusia estamos hablando del
nuevo mega gasoductoso YouTube y amigos
de completarse esos tres proyectos la
capacidad de exportación de Rusia hacia
china se multiplicaría lo que abarataría
las importaciones de gaschinas y además
incrementaría su seguridad de suministro
además teniendo en cuenta el nuevo
aislamiento que vive Rusia Seguro seguro
que china sabe cómo arrancar la creme en
las condiciones más favorables
[Música]
y de hecho las sanciones impuestas sobre
Rusia nos llevan a pensar incluso que la
relación entre Pekín y Moscú se pueda
desequilibrar aún más y que el kremlin
se vuelva muy pero que muy dependiente
de sustratos con china Entonces será
momento en el que el régimen de sigue
pin pondrá en práctica una de sus
especialidades favoritas la diplomacia
Sugar Daddy que es la diplomacia Sugar
Daddy pues os lo explicamos en un pasado
vídeo de visualpolitik lo hará cuando la
posición de Rusia se haya debilitado
tanto que llega un punto en el que el
Sugar Daddy chino empieza a exigir cosas
a las que Rusia simple y llanamente no
se podrá negar ahora bien realmente está
China dispuesta a rescatar a la economía
rusa pues ojo porque en un próximo vídeo
aquí en visualpolitik os responderemos a
esta pregunta con todo lujo de detalle
así que no olvides suscribirte y darle a
la campanita pero de momento turno para
ti Qué papel pensáis que debería
desempeñar sigue pin ante la Guerra de
Ucrania creéis que china en algún
momento cambiará su postura de apoyar
simultáneamente las demandas de unos y
de otros podéis dejarnos vuestras
respuestas por aquí abajo en los
comentarios y ahora si este vídeo se ha
resultado interesante no olvidéis darle
al botón de like una vez más Muchas
gracias por estar ahí un saludo y hasta
la próxima
[Música]